bien au-dessus odieuse comprendre cette
compilation de 5e ce que m'avait envoyé
plusieurs jeux que j'ai passé en vidéo
ce que je suis un court mais un moyen
compte aujourd'hui joueur à terre pour
l'exemple dans une seule vidéo j'ai créé
un [ __ ] de jeu pour toi de benjamin et
squeeze jeu passera pas mais j'étais le
dernier passait dans ta vidéo j'appelle
mes abonnés une standard promis un jeu
régal toi on va se régaler jouer
création de squeeze et création du
visage question d'un corps musclé c'est
pas mon jeu alors moi c'est moi qui le
dit c'est lui tu as l'air d'un monstre
redoutable
oh non non là déjà je me met pas en
valeur mais toi tu me tues me masse à
coups de pelle mon gars on est sur un
léger souci au niveau du visage
clic gauche pour attaquer c'est fait
exprès mais que c'est fait exprès dans
snow fairy se prête mal andy rhis toi là
dedans la demande en quoi quoi donc quoi
benjamin ou à le relancer à c'est bon là
ça remarche au képi d'un squeeze c'est
moi bendis police
benji tu fais des gueules mon gars ici
tous les habitants ont un nombre qui se
termine par folie ok sauf toi quoi je
l'anc réussir tous les challenges pour
devenir le grand squeeze police a les
infos que pasqua ou rzeszut ouais
d'accord sa part sur un siège de foot en
fait tu dois me toucher avec la balle ok
non la balle s'est arrêtée
allez allez allez on va réussir on a
réussi à benjamin la balle est coincé la
balle est coincé baglama oui encore oh
non non à lait de noix bonbons police et
on passe à la suite oui j'adore ça
encore mais arrête [ __ ] oui encore
mais arrête faut faire combien de fois
allez c'est bon là fiouf un régal à un
sur six dernières belles c'est trop dire
du challenge une chance sur trois oh non
c'est droite à la gauche
ok milieu howie droite oui qu'est ce que
c'est que ça une batte de base-ball faut
que je me défonce blanc wife est trop
bas et que tu as eue contradictoires
tu vas lui comme chez soi c'est le
battre est ce que tu m'as fait un corps
musclé que je suis fort pour autant à
plat
hop là ok en fait faut que je recule si
je recule et apache trois techniques hop
là encore je te défonce
quand je te défonce bien bas à 306 est
bon pour l'avenir terre [ __ ] comme
dans la vraie vie régulièrement je me
bats et je suis extrêmement fort suivant
altissimo faire foi et là-dessus train
[ __ ] un parcours d'obstacles a fait
siennes les pièges mec mais franchement
à petit chaque fois j'aimerais ça
coûtait quoi bien mériter le polygone de
pseudo mais est-ce que c'est celui-là on
va je pensais à ce budget ouais
ensuite en face aux à gauche c'est plus
loin ouais à gauche on paye tout droit
c'est un peu loin là je pense qu'il faut
faire le grand saut
non mais ça continue et du premier coup
buts choqué en mémoire yes ok c'est quoi
la c koi ensuite ramène-moi le ballon de
foot mais non ok donc je prends ballon
de foot du de la première énigme il faut
que je ramène tout d'abord les mecs et
un possible contrôle est à fait exprès
tu le sais allez allez allez
griezmann est en nous griezmann est en
nous par contre il faut enchaîner sur
autre chose que je vois c'est autre
chose et que le retrait pour le ballon
htc bon tiens oh oui ok le dernier c'est
quoi oh là là on trouve les panneaux
squeeze ben tu veux pécho traire mes
vidéos ça oh oui oh oui alors à
plusieurs noms tum ans et les deux
derrière
[Musique]
voulzy folie musique merci pour ton dieu
était géniale en plus maintenant j'ai
doit napper squeeze police donc c'est la
folie aller alors second jeu studio
crafts je t'écris un fan game sur
gamekult aps le bras n'est pas musclé
pour que ça soit plus réaliste
voilà alors le mec sait pas écrire jeté
une critique le jeu marche pas missing
appoint faut pour pourra pas voir le
bras peu vu ce qu'est que tu m'avais
fait bon je suis désolé studio kraft
allez hop un abonné en moins alors ses
excuses j'ai créé un jeu pour thoiras
jean va pas se mentir que j'ai posée sur
google drive the man who sold his
virility l'homme qui avait vendu sa
virilité
ok ok c'est parti donc ces injures
agences et ça j'ai perdu qu alors c'est
quoi cet accord at on trop d'infos la
seconde en place ce qu'ils disent tu vas
faire là ya des pics geôles ces merdes
au plafond mais truc passé à [ __ ]
c'est dur quand même
et j'ai même pas bougé même pas avancer
comme le ping pong [ __ ] à mais on a
des double sens j'envie zeljko c'est moi
au chaud ou tiède à bata hockey alors
c'est quoi le piège oh mais c'est dur
jean guilbault commencé pour passer la
wii
alors où il ya des pics ok je sais y'a
pas de lui ah j'ai tourné jasper trop
vite et trop fort we see the fucking
gbagbo les fondeurs mapa ghana ou le
piège à ta petite brique invisible à uri
caine en rase-mottes l'estrie c'est du
poison
l'amap j'ai jamais autant détesté le fil
et boum
yes yes man fou parce que là d un
checkpoint mon gars est là on trace
mongai hollow au [ __ ] vert c'est quoi
ce week-end d'accord vous c'est quoi
ok assez la fin c'est le n 2 n 2 enzo a
dansé enzo d'accord en l'epic enzo lucas
bon là c'est roulage en elle la jeune
homme aimait gaymard devant le visage de
[ __ ] hockey ahl et puis c'est trop c'est
trop j'en ai marre merci pour le jeu
voilà jérémy coucou lui cache main
dessus pour toi les abonnés sur unity 3d
super tu va l'aimer c'est un quiz os
with it le meilleur jeu de mots à ce
quizz gérer mais je suis surtout jeu ça
formidable
vu ton talent pour les jeux de mots
allez on commence il a déjà fait la
scène vous ne passerez pas dans le film
le seigneur des anneaux avec son chat
alors vrai ou il a prêté sa voix au film
la désolation de smaug ouais je pèse
ouais c'est vrai mythomane démasqué il a
déjà tapé dans un cadre c'est vrai et
ouais j'ai réagi je tapais dans un cadre
et 20 points de suture parce que vous
devez a bien coupé la main il à notre
chaîne youtube nommé squeeze gaming
c'est vrai manque et commence à manquer
jouera on s'est mis d'accord avec
cyprien ça se discute gaming il est
tombé plusieurs fois de sa chaise
pendant ces vidéos jamais ça m'arrivera
mais thomas des basques il a ainsi dans
le lien et squeeze points comme c'est
faux c'est d'accord
donc j'ai un site qui vend les jouets
les plus moche du monde ok faut il va
faire ce quiz aux vrais réussi relevé
qu'il était sûr de lui jérémy attention
un trop de confiance en toi ils gagnent
moins de 18 euros par mois faut il gagne
au moins un million par vidéo il à notre
chaîne youtube nommé se plaint gaming
qu'il partage avec ce prêt un c'est faux
elle s'appelle squeeze gaming manqué et
s'est fait percer l'oreille en ce1 et
ouais
thomas kvist à son profil quiz de 30
questions maintenant tu reconnais un peu
plus sur ce fabuleux youtuber ray
tsafack ego je m'attendais à faire une
fellation soit n'hésite pas à
recommencer pour essayer d'avoir moins
d'erreurs pour revoir les questions pour
faudra voir sacré vaut pour le commencé
quand même il dit au témoin l'aurait
josiane cette vidéo sur ses trois petits
fans gays n'hésitez pas allez messieurs
a plus un grand merci à ceux qui m'ont
envoyé ces petits jeux c'est adorable
ses manières très mignonne de vote rick
vous aimez les vidéos et participer à la
création et puis écoutez ci-haut matière
pour faire une compilation de fair game
un jour je le ferais vous en faites pas
je vous dis à très vite
portez vous bien un tiers monde pis il
est notre chaîne youtube nommé squeeze
gaming vrai
[Musique]